[Musique]
en se moquant bonsoir la normandie à 16
ans je voulais être chirurgien en
afrique
et oui on ne disait pas encore
chirurgienne je vais partager avec vous
ce soir les grands moments de ma vie
ceux qui m'ont permis de réaliser mes
rêves je suis laurence contre asus je
suis président de medtronic france un
acteur majeur de la santé et du
dispositif médical comme l'a dit harry
le pacemaker mais aussi le pansement ou
les irm j'habite à quelques kilomètres
d'ici
avec ma famille mes deux filles de 18 et
22 ans et mon mari kinésithérapeute
je ne suis pas chirurgienne en afrique
mais j'ai bien réaliser mon rêve celui
de travail et dans la santé
il n'y a pas de hasard il y a des étapes
il y a plein de phases dans une vie et
en définitive nous sommes très peu
préparés à passer d'une phase à une
autre ou d'une saison à une autre comme
je vais le partager avec vous un point
commun à toutes ces saisons
être une femme dans un monde d'hommes je
vous propose que l'on commence par la
première saison l'étudiante
j'ai un bac e en poche pour ceux qui
approche la cinquantaine
vous vous souvenez peut-être aïe aïe aïe
oui préfère le bas que c'était
mathématiques physique et pique nique
mon père et moi pensons que nous
n'arriverons pas à financer ces fameuses
études de médecine c'est l'heure de mon
tout premier virage je me dirige alors
vers les stars à belfort pour devenir
ingénieur technico-commercial
ce ne sera pas médecine mais j'ai
confiance
ce que je veux c'est apprendre apprendre
à apprendre apprendre à me connaître et
apprendre à innover ce ne sera pas des
années toujours facile financièrement
mais il ya toujours une solution
et puis il y à de belles rencontres
il y à des stages à l'étranger il y à
des stages dans le médical et un dernier
stage en marketing chez gec alsthom et
là une évidence s'impose à moi je veux
travailler avec les gens je veux un
métier de contact
je veux travailler en équipe je ne veux
pas être enfermé dans un bureau
je veux travailler sur le terrain ce ne
sera pas gec-alsthom ce grand groupe
mais technico commercial je vous propose
donc que l'on enchaîne sur ma deuxième
saison technico commercial les choses
sont évidentes pour moi je veux être
technico-commercial je veux être sur le
terrain et je veux être une maman c'est
un peu à l'époque comme vouloir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
je me rends bien compte
qui va falloir que j'assume mes
ambitions que je sache ce que je veux et
ce que je ne veux pas pour moi tout
passera par l'organisation
mais il faudra aussi accepter le regard
des autres
savoir ce que l'on veut et savoir qu'ils
louent mais je passe ainsi 18 mois dans
l'informatique
ce sont des années plein de défis 300%
150 e fax par jour vous souvenez il n'y
avait pas de smartphone à l'époque et
des prospects à aller convaincre le
courage et l'envi drive ronces et 18
mois et à ce moment-là l'heure de mon
deuxième virage je fais la connaissance
d'une américaine qui gère ah j'ai oublié
elles travaillent dans la santé bien sûr
pour un grand groupe
elle gère toute la france elle ne parle
pas un mot de français
à 23 ans je décide d'aller travailler
avec elle je prends la moitié de la
france de strasbourg à brest
c'est un marché en pleine mutation
j'adore mais surtout jeu permet à des
patients qui ont un cancer de
l'oesophage ou du poumon de vivre
quelques mois ou quelques années de plus
c'est l'heure de ma troisième saison
celle de la maman marketers qui s'assume
je n'ai jamais mis en avant mon statut
de femme bien au contraire mais je suis
quand même un peu une enquiquineuse donc
pour ma première fille je fais une
grossesse difficile finit évidemment le
terrain retour au marketing moins de
contacts mais de beaux projets j'ai
confiance retour de mon congé maternité
je prends un poste ma fille à peine né
je prends un poste de manager
je gère l'ensemble de l'équipe des
électro physiologie je vous épargne la
recherche sur google ce sont tous les
dysfonctions
du coeur et là je suis femme j'ai 27 ans
et un bébé
je fais mon entrée au comité de
direction il y à de très belles
rencontres
ce ne sera pas non plus tous les jours
facile et il y à un conseil assez vite
d'ailleurs que je vais suivre continuer
à grandir en dehors de la société
à ce moment là une société m'offre cette
chance je la saisis il faut savoir
saisir les opportunités et c'est quand
même plus facile de les saisir
quand on sait ce que l'on veut
évidemment c'est l'heure de ma quatrième
saison
une femme dans un monde d'hommes
avec le recul je me rends compte que en
fait j'ai pris tous les postes que mes
collègues masculins ne voulait pas trop
de challenge
je suis resté une femme dans un monde
d'hommes
j'ai appris à connaître leurs codes
c'était assez passionnant et puis à à un
moment en fait oui alzheimer même quand
on travaille dans la santé arrive même
quand on parle de sa propre vie donc à
ce moment là en fait je me dis que
vais-je continuer à faire dans ce monde
dans ce monde d'hommes et bien là je
prends une nouvelle équipe je dirige les
six plus importants vendeurs d'une
société et cette société elle s'appelle
medtronic
en effet j'ai passé huit ans dans la
première partie de ma carrière
et là j'arrive chez medtronic medtronic
pour ceux qui connaissent un peu le
monde de la santé ou le monde de
dispositif médical c'est comme un rêve
c'est d'ailleurs tellement un rêve que
je prends un poste moins haut
on y est rare chi que celui que j'avais
donc je dirige ces six personnes les
plus âgées et les plus expérimentés de
la société
au passage j'adresse une pensée toute
particulière à mon manager de l'époque
décédé il ya quelques années de la
maladie de charcot cas confiance ta
bienveillance mon permis un retour au
haut comité de direction et pour un
poste pas des moindres je dirige l'unité
de chirurgie cardiaque
je continue à avancer il y à de belles
rencontres des rencontres
internationales des rencontres avec les
équipes françaises avec avec les clients
et puis avec beaucoup de courage le
courage de refuser les postes que l'on
propose et le courage de postuler à ce
qu on ne me propose pas savoir ce que
l'on aime savoir ce que l'on veut tout
se passait très bien mes filles
mon mari mes équipes tout est un petit
peu trop huilée ne trouvez pas eh bien
oui alors j'accepte de faire un mba et
au brésil tout en gérant la deuxième
entité de la société et au même moment
mon mari décide de reprendre des études
de médecine pour être kinésithérapeute
aucun de nous ne sera basée à caen il
nous faudra du courage il nous faudra de
l'organisation et il nous faudra de la
bienveillance celle des autres
d'ailleurs qu'il faut aller demander car
il ya quelque chose que j'ai appris
quand on aime les gens
ils vous le rendent alors nous avançons
et là une nouvelle opportunité se
présente
réunir l'ensemble des équipes
cardiovasculaire de la société faire un
pilote français pour montrer la voix à
l'europe
c'est un peu comme si on vous demandait
de réunir le foot et le rugby dans la
même équipe
vous imaginez et quelques années passent
et une idée fait son chemin
je me verrais bien un jour à la tête
de medtronic france et c'est déjà
l'heure de ma cinquième saison
c'est un peu comme la lumière qu'il
revient il y a maintenant presque cinq
ans nous rachetons une société presque
aussi grosses que nous et la jeune dit
laurence tu vas pas y couper
on va te proposer un poste à l'europe
tout ce que je veux pas trop difficile
avec les enfants alors je passe quand
même les entretiens est toujours ma
petite idée en tête pas l'europe la
france
je sais ce que je veux je sais ce que je
ne veux pas bon pour être tout à fait
honnête cette fois ci je suis plus
vraiment très sûr de moi et mon patron
actuel vient me voir et me dit laurence
je te propose la présidence de medtronic
france à toi de réussir le regroupement
de ces deux entités
waouh moi je ne croyais pas mes oreilles
avoir le poste dont j'avais rêvé
présidente de medtronic france cela fait
cinq ans et je dois encore me faire à
tout ce qui va avec l'impact
la visibilité la médiatisation tout ce
qu'on attend de moi moi en fait tout ce
que je veux c'est faire des choses
nouvelles
faire des partenariats travailler avec
mes équipes travaillent et en externe
alors on fait un nouveau comité
stratégique
évidemment on met une vision en place
avec l'intelligence collective
pour y arriver on innove à tous les
étages
et c'est à ce moment là que la diversité
et l'inclusion entre dans ma vie quand
je prend le poste de medtronic france
tous les éléments féminins viennent me
voir
elles me disent tout la même chose
laurence maintenant que tu es président
tu doit nous aider
elles ont souvent des questions très
simples comment tu t'es organisée
comment tu fais pour east et qui tu es
et là je me rends compte qu'il ne s'agit
pas uniquement de la question de la
femme dans l'entreprise que ce n'est pas
plus simple
que d'être de couleurs que d'être
handicapé que d'être jeune ou que d'être
seniors peu importe la bienveillance que
l'on porte aux gens ma boussole à moi
elle n'a pas changé se connaître et
s'assumer mais malgré cette
bienveillance
ce n'est pas si simple alors je prend à
bras le corps ce sujet de la diversité
et de l'inclusion au passage ça permet
de traiter la parité sous un angle
beaucoup moins clivant
alors je fais de l'innovation du
management de la parité de la diversité
et de l'inclusion des engagements
personnels
j'en fais aussi des clés de succès de
mon entreprise et de mon épanouissement
en tant que présidente et oui tout cela
est possible même dans un grand groupe
je sais qui je suis et pour cela j'ai
appris à connaître et à m'accepter
l'amour des gens et la bienveillance
m'ont toujours accompagnée
j'en suis très fier et très heureuse je
n'ai pas encore construit mes prochaines
saisons j'y travaille
on m'a récemment demandé mais qui prend
soin de vous eh bien ma famille et mes
équipes
mesdames soyez bien accompagné messieurs
aussi billard je n'aurais pas pu rester
qui je suis être qui je suis
sans mon mari sébastien qui est dans la
salle je ne pourrais pas être qui je
suis professionnellement sans lui sans
mes équipes sont les personnes que j'ai
pu côtoyer ou écouter car on apprend
tellement des autres et on apprend de
tout le monde
soyez curieux soyez libres soyez vous
même parce que le vrai changement c'est
être soi merci de votre attention
[Musique]